all right and I think we are finally
finally live
welcome everybody to episode 106 of the
iron Lords podcast due to some
unforeseen technical difficulties we
apologize for the 12 minutes late but
we're here we're ready to go finally so
as you can tell
Lord sovereign at the helm once again
holding down the hosting duties as the
boss Lord Cognito recuperates from a
little procedure he had so we wish him a
speedy recovery either disabled should
not be disabled this is check is
disabled for those live chat
I've chat is in there all right cool
we expect to have card back next week we
were some speedy recovery I know he's
listening and I know he's he's kind of
out of it but I know he's around alright
so big shout out to our two special
guests these two gentlemen really need
no introduction these guys are brethren
family to the realm but I'll introduce
them nonetheless so let's start out with
the creator and host of the basement
radio arcade podcast and YouTube channel
the man with the most epic rants and all
of YouTube them that's a word I don't
know if that's a word and the man who
will smite all who engaged in any fanboy
talk making this return to the
roundtable Lord Henry K aka Lord black
what's going on my brother thank you for
coming through gentlemen it is a
pleasure to be back I am so excited to
be on today you know especially with boo
I mean when I heard boom was on I'm like
yes have you guys been on any shows
together yeah
it's just this is just the first one for
ILP okay yes yeah yeah yeah being on
boobs channel he's been on my channel
we've been on mooches channel crossfire
together
of course oh yeah so no gentlemen it's
an honor when you reached out to me and
asked if I could make today I said
absolutely you guys are family and you
know anything I can do to help you guys
out man you know I'm always here for you
guys so much love appreciate it and
ready talk some video games Thank You
Man thank you for coming through we
really really appreciate it man
so of course next up I have to take let
me take a swig of water first next up we
have the man who in a few short weeks
will be gracing the hallowed halls of
the LA Convention Center and the
Microsoft theater arm and arm with the
Lord's he is the creator of
double-barrel gaming on YouTube the
creator and host a breakfast with boom
oh man what else is back there podcast
and goon with salty our friend salty yes
anything else I'm missing know that
that's enough on my plate please to the
round table mr. boomstick XL new
Rochelle's finest thank you for joining
us brother I really appreciate it what's
up man oh dude first of all when I when
you asked me it was automatic right I
have to be our Fuhrer we gave was gonna
be honestly got that's dope King is
gonna be here you're gonna be here it's
to say it's a shame that you know that
we're a little light with the you know
with the Lords but you know and it seems
to be under the table somewhere you know
he's uh Alec we'll be back eventually we
know Cognito which is is definitely
recovering I talked to him it's great
because you know I have such a great
relationship but everyone on this panel
and to be here it's just complete honor
so let's get this show on the road man
yes sir
definitely definitely man this day just
threw me off man you know like I'm a
rookie at this so once the technical
difficulties just jump in like it messes
me up I'm so it does it'll be hard man
my stomach is doing backflips I'm like
this sucks
III thought you were gonna like throw
the computer out the window man yeah
because it's never anything obvious so
you just like your try and get throwing
everything at the wall see if it sticks
but thankfully it worked all it took was
for braaap to DM boom for whatever is
that worked
so you're gonna work right to get a
hangouts call right that's it exactly
that part right let me introduce the
remaining two of the Four Horsemen of
gaming as we have attic the under the
bus we have no idea what's up with attic
and as I said the boss Lord kognito is
on disability this week but a we should
have him back next week so of course we
have the Incredible Hulk of the ILP with
the O with the Incredible Hulk of the
ILP the lousiest XS gamer and the king
of all statues and combat talk King
wassup my brother so you this weekend
you got lit man a lot of talk going on
bro let me tell you some first of all um
Kos is up so go see that Linda caught a
tribute yeah I get the holy trinity yes
yeah take it the whole thing
hope you're part of the Instagram
Facebook and Twitter links alright um I
can't put the music on YouTube okay so
you're not gonna get the whole tribute
unless you're part of the Instagram
Facebook and Twitter it so you can see
those links days you can actually see
what I put together for one of the most
powerful man
my time and the reason why I collected
that Wonderwoman statute she was at the
forefront of the feminist movement
pushing women forward she was at the
pinnacle of my brain of how women are
viewed through my eyes strong confident
independent heroism is just she and
beauty like she was my like my shining
star as far as that's that's how beauty
starch the starch they're so you know
King goes that way
now far as fights combat talk we're not
close to shield versus Christina hammer
and last night um I wasn't gonna cover
that fight because I thought it was
gonna be another tomato can wash out
type of thing but then I started digging
deeper into Christina hammer and I
noticed a lot of her fights and these
guys was on a collision path so I had to
give these women they just do and it
appends out exactly how I thought it was
no pan out Christina hammer was trying
to you know establish a jab trying to
get her right hand into a play and a
couple of times she did do those things
early on but I am but like I said I
believe the weight of the gloves for the
women fighters are issue also I believe
don't hamstring them we're giving them
two-minute rounds give them three minute
12 rounds just like the men because you
don't want to water down the product if
you want the product to be the same give
them the same but this is how you get
the fights to be crisp and because it
turns it's sometimes it turns into slap
Festus there's no disrespect for women
um and its but we see this in young
amateurs so because their gloves is a
little bit heavier so when when we go up
to actual arm professional ranks the
gloves turn to be lighter and they
become sharper and they become maybe
they're able to move a little bit better
so if we can get that for the women I I
guarantee you the product will change
and will be something that you will want
to see but shout out arm Clarissa she
did exactly what I expected her to do
push the fight was written
termination and willpower when somebody
is chasing greatness greatness is not
gonna be stopped if they had that door
they're banging at the door and they're
kicking that door down and they won't
what's inside that door they're gonna
get it and she got it and god bless her
that was a fantastic fight when she
calls up the quote the greatest women
woman of all time she came a whole name
sound like something that you kill your
feet so but um shout out today I was a
great fight Fonz you hit the nail on the
head it was a good fight um especially
low mishchenko this weekend he's
knocking out knocked out Carolla um that
fight
everybody thinks a Corolla was a bum
actually he's not he's not I know he's
not like yeah that was something else
yeah just you're seeing greatness you're
seeing like when we got a chance to see
Roy Jones when we got a chance to see
young like Jason young Randy Holyfield
when we got a chance to see and for
older people when they got a chance to
see Muhammad Ali when he fought Sonny
Liston
you understand um these rare butterflies
come and they blossom writer from the
eyes and they make the impossible easy
and this man is in this ring the same
way he walks around and he trains I see
it I see him switching feet I see him
moving his hands and sliding slipping
throwing punches effortlessly off the
top of his head the man is a savant is
he is probably one of the greatest of
our time and I want to see him fight
Mikey I need to see that yeah I
definitely need to see that as well I
think these guys hopefully with the
breaking down of a lot of these
contracts and these TV these TV
contracts we start to see more of these
these fights happening and people be
more willing to face each other because
it sucks that fighters of a certain
generation that should be going
toe-to-toe it hasn't been happening so
we solve we've been dealing with that oh
oh like I know we have in the nature of
boxing right
and asking Bob Arum yeah that's kind of
why I know I know that's why yeah I know
that's why cog gravitated and I started
gravitating to it to UFC and MMA in
general just because the league the
league mentality so it forces you to put
those guys in front of each other know
you know and it's it's a wolf product
didn't MMA had a great weekend um I'm
frightened right now I missed everything
I was on the show because I was reading
all Fine's tweets yes brought it I'm
fronting good I actually went well okay
so now Floyd sovereign the offline
profile Illuminati lives for the single
prayer offline experience these guys do
not let me go back to the hole from
which I came they want me to engage
freak incognito and King they're like no
you're gonna be at the forefront I'm
like no don't want to do it tell me let
me let me give you I got a tip my hat to
you sir
you took my hat to you on that video
that you and I did that video that I
said yeah over here and make sure that
we talked to warhorse that video where
I'm like yeah cog let's go homeless
sovereign let's go get stand up there
and let's do it reviews right now 20,000
is crazy was insane to lord Toby
shoutout to Lord Rick everybody over at
warhorse shout out the game star man one
of the the biggest publications in
Europe suffered using the iron Lords of
video you know in their article and
whatnot that's that's what's up that's
all sensation I know they love that man
look Mick scruffy hello man to be honest
this week
I haven't played Jack in the last two
weeks I picked up the the Phoenix Wright
Ace Attorney of the trilogy or whatever
cuz I haven't played them ever
I picked it up on a switch trying to
give my switch a little bit of love
because it hasn't been collecting dust
and I have to say so I did that but I
haven't even booted it up so I haven't
played anything yesterday went out with
Lord Marlow Gnaeus we were down to lord
lorik I bought two and of course Lord
Cod couldn't make it yesterday but we
went to see Shazam I thought it was
great man I think it's funny how like
roles have come sort of been reversed in
terms like the comedic stuff I think DC
realizes that they need to give you
characters that are relatable and fun
without all the over the overtly dark
tones but what are you honest mm-hmm an
insane yet but the comic has always been
in a lighter tone it has oh we haven't
regardless of the character strength and
his company how comparable he is to
Superman in a lot of ways yes the
characters always been a lot lighter um
and I think they did that great service
in the movie you understand that because
he's actually a kid he doesn't
understand the responsibility that comes
with these powers up front but I think a
manager question this is the one I've
always had a problem with Graham right
um he has the wisdom of Solomon right
right so once he turns into Shazam
should he be automatically wise that is
that is one of those things that you say
okay why would he not just become a
different being altogether and be
someone else when he becomes Shazam
right but I guess if yeah I get that I
totally get that and makes sense in
terms of the way they explain the
character in the way you should be but I
think you'd have a boring character at
that point right maybe maybe you might
have a boring character being a douche I
mean absolutely but I thought it was
great I thought Zachary Levi was
fantastic in the role I don't know about
the you know all the talk about the
padding in the suit the padding no
that's true that's all him doing the I
saw a video of how he gets in shape that
guy went really him yeah he got ripped
up for this rude me he would watch the
video yeah he went up to 224 yeah I'll
cut back down to 215 and then the
trainer that they had him working with
because he was going to show he got the
role a whole year in advance mm-hmm and
they told his behind
in shape up here in events so the show
that he was on it xscape me because I
don't watch it the show that he was on
you saw his transformation on that show
as the season went on another man was
getting stout he was yeah that's all the
jib man that is all legit him and he
changed his eating habits like crazy
mm-hmm I watched a video on I was like I
was stunned he said that he said that
he's thankful for that because that
often times when you have to do certain
things for a moving NATO that like
affects your personal life in a way that
you know it gives you creates habits and
you that you sort of stick with he said
for me that was the biggest thing like
it's getting away from drinking you know
stop the eating crap and stuff like that
so that to me that's a cool thing and
obviously it doesn't hurt that you know
that Warner Brothers just paid for
everything so he because they wouldn't
get ripped on yeah I wish somebody would
give me a nutritionist and told me that
listen here's a couple of million go
work your behind out and don't worry
about don't worry about nothing else
you're paid for everything
go big shout out to Philly Eagle in the
chat with the $5 super chat good morning
lords hope everyone is having a
fantastic Sunday looking forward to a
great podcast thank you so much for the
Eagle you always in here representing
and looking out for the Lord so thank
you so much my brother appreciate it so
now that we've talked about Shazam we're
gonna talk to our our two esteemed
guests once again I know that we usually
go back into their their histories and
stuff and and what they've done what
brought them to YouTube but we've
already done this yeah it's like I said
these guys are brethren to the realm so
if you want to check out Lord raps first
appearance on I open you have to go back
all the way to Il p38
Wow were to get 38 is the first time
Lord brat graced us with his presence
that dad that's a long time ago brother
yeah and of course for Lord boom with a
little later a little later we got Lord
boom on for the first time on episode
773 of IOP yep so if you guys want to
know about that gaming history how they
got into YouTube and how they came to be
where they are today please go back and
listen to those what I want to talk to
these guys
right now is what's going on with your
channels now like what you guys have
anything new going on I know braaap has
I mean I don't know boom has a laundry
list of things that he's doing let's
start out what I want to ask you guys is
what's going on with the channel now
anything new anything you have planned
for the future and then addition to that
what is your guys assessment of what's
been going on 2019 so far we're four
months I let Enrique go because I'm a
gentleman and I'm good to hear what he
has to say because you know what the
Breyer I listen I went on a campaign for
braaap and I would have done it if I
didn't believe in them oh absolutely
panel is unbelievable great group of
guys is great topics that are very
honest yeah yeah so I saw week a please
take it away
no you know boom I appreciate it man I
really do you know boom was very
instrumental really helping us get over
that that 1k you know sub mark and so I
always appreciate his his support you
know up rap and everyone who has
supported us over the last 2 2 or 3
years that we've been doing this now but
in terms of the channel you know we're
just putting out weekly podcast
on Wednesday nights at 9:00 p.m. Eastern
Daylight Time and you know I do my rants
when I can you had you had a recent one
that we'll be talking about a little
while yeah yeah yeah kind of interesting
so so I did I did a rant over the issue
it or issue I guess the issue that
people are having with remedies new game
but yeah I mean you know we're um you
know behind the scenes trying to try to
get some developers on but it's been
it's been tough you know everyone's kind
of uh you know in in the e3 grind and
it's yeah yeah talk about anything yeah
yeah you know I've been trying to get
Marcella Taman who's who was at he
worked for Crytek and I was at ubi and
that's been you know movies a little
more a little more hands-on with
allowing their employ on podcast so
that's been that's been a little bit
challenge
we're working on that behind the scenes
um but yeah I mean that's that's pretty
much it I mean you know I think we just
you're just focusing on putting out you
know content and just it's having fun
and having conversations about the hobby
that we love and enjoy so much and you
know and and you know gotta give a big
shout out to Eric Jackson and be money
he's actually been a little m.i.a cuz he
just bought a new house and been you
know working with that and yeah and you
know big shout out to uh slow-mo and E
and gaming yeah for take get at me man I
got at you in the DMZ you you don't like
free stuff brother
I got your teespring on deck man you
know what you need man yeah yeah for
tape man hit him up man he said he's in
the live chat right now he is I just did
not contact me I know that no love
whatsoever you know Eric Jack Eric you
know Eric and B have been uh you know
mainstays in the podcast for four years
now and so we're just having fun man you
know just just love talking about you
know video games and everything related
to the industry so in terms of 2019 it's
been a great year for gaming already I
mean we really as definitely do month of
April I've been playing I've been
playing sick row shadows die twice let's
go let's talk about it and let me tell
you something
it's probably from hardest game that
I've played um but I love it it's as
much as I curse the game and I yelling
at my TV at times I just keep coming
back you know I've gotten to play since
PAX East but I'm the same way I love I
love sucking at that game the but thing
but it takes me back to a time where you
know we grew up in the you know the
eighties and nineties you see games
right there you see that right there
those are no actually aren't all right
that game that you print that are
playing is purposely made in a way to
make you throw and break controllers
tear up TVs but but I think you could
say the same thing about those Olga
those old ane really Alan sing it out
were made to eat quarters they were made
to make you poor that's what they were
maybe that made it hard he kept feeding
the quarters yes all right now in the
age of $200 controllers and $5,000
televisions you're playing a dangerous
game brother I've seen guys go
absolutely nuts out out the kids smooth
brother you have the best reactions to
that move dude I gotta move man he's
willing to put his misery out there I
mean I mean the price the price I
wouldn't do it $4,000 $4,000 I think but
you see he did it very good it's like
some people do $1,000 challenge and
they're not entertaining this man got a
calculation of all his oh it's the best
it's genuine but the boy is very genuine
or he's yes his reaction like even we
did he beat bloodborne
right when he do like a flip on his bed
like we almost broke his neck like yes
PAX East or did he did he just no
backsies but I understand exactly why he
was there last year and I'm saying did
he beat the bloodborne challenge at PAX
East are we rolling there but no I think
he was it was PAX East he was playing it
I think I think Eric was like in the
background like we'd like walk imagine
addict in the background like because he
was screaming he was like any of us he
did like a flip off to bed but it was
funny but but no that came I mean that
game brings me back to a time where we
used to gain like like ghosting combos
it was hard back in the days even into
the early ninja guidance weren't easy at
oh gee if you remember at og hmm once it
was it really an easy game
you know these this game just as much as
I cursed at the TV want to throw my cold
I keep coming back because it's
rewarding like it when you actually beat
a boss you finally beat their boss it is
so rewarding and you just want to keep
going back for more and it took me away
II so King that's why I haven't been on
the division - man yeah I'm upset with
you I won't be a hunnit with you I'm
just like honey because um this and I
said this is always going down with
Brock I'm glad that you are on the show
so I can have my king intervention home
you did it in pubs you listen I don't
know how you maintain relationships
brother but let me tell you something
like once once once once once we hang
out once we're dating okay all right so
and every time I jump on I jump on same
bat-time
yeah my man Bret we enemies DC streets
no I'm in these DC streets alone shout
out the Lord monkey for getting me up to
30 and shout out to this guy's name um
sorry excuse me again I'm hungry
brothers I did not eat so my food my
stomach is eating my thoughts
um but yeah they got me to Gare we up to
tier 5 shout-out to Chris Lord Chris we
are here we're moving I was trying to
get bribe doing it we was with native
the other day we we leveled native up
from four levels and I thinking like 15
minutes
well I mean King we were on there for I
mean a while a minute but you know it go
came out man it just it keeps calling me
my friend left my friend left I got a
problem with a lot of you guys on this
panel all get a new unboxing video King
I thought you like this ha it's sending
that to me boom is nice like that for
you something
[Laughter]
it's just it's like in the corner over
bro I got but he's going to eat three so
he more than made up for it he was at
PAX so my man is like you listen I'm
probably not playing with you in a game
but I'm with you in real life always
listen to hell with your spirit
I mean physically or virtually to show
up brother I'm listening you're here
right now this is a step in the right
direction but you know he runs me
through the bushes every week he's knows
until we finished playing a way out I'm
not I'm never gonna be able to build me
up early goodnight your ticker oh here
oh absolutely 100% I'm addicted to
getting murdered in that game it is the
best feeling I look at it to me I feel
in terms of combat it is the most
evolved combat and a from game ever I
think it may forces you to use every
aspect of a combat in a level design to
in the level design they've always been
masters of level design the way the
levels double back on each other and it
almost feels kind of like a Metroidvania
in that way when you open up like
different paths that you weren't able to
go through before and you just you see
how things sort of intertwine on top of
one another it's freaking amazing man
it's just a matter of having the
patience to stick with it and no not
everybody has that patience but out old
school that's how we used to play that
so I feel like that's how he grew up
playing it's okay you were playing a
street fighter earlier on the okay what
you heard is like when you go from when
you change systems okay I will jump from
thing they do random sounds you don't
have nothing to do with it okay oh you
came in for no reason
has nothing to do with it so dealing
from Atari something or whatever yeah
yeah but it's 6,000 small games you know
um and I'm gonna get that arcade stuff
to you and turn that down I'm get that
arcade stuff to you you're working on
how to present it to you legally and we
want you guys to be the most driving
force in that like picking games you see
how Brad said old-school games right I
want and he mention the name and I was
gonna go search for the game in here but
I need to know the company who makes the
game and I mean yeah I can get into it I
can get the game I can post the game and
I can show Brad yo Brad go check this
out I'm playing this and I can do a
little review on it you know a 2019
review on a game that was back out in
the 80s and you bring it to an audience
that may not have even gotten to play
because a lot of our chat have not
played those games you understand so if
I give you a rocket if I can strike a
fire in you I can give some type of
awareness that's why that statue is
spinning in the background it's it's
it's showing you there yeah you can go
and purchase that statue I will show you
the link I will tell you what to do you
don't have to limit yourself at all ever
not one time will you should you or any
way you can limit yourself you should go
out and work to your fullest potential
if you collect and collect don't let
nobody make you feel small or demean you
if you play video games play your video
games because I grew up in a climate
that going into the arcade and playing
video games day was talking down us we
empower our children now our children
have us to back them you know perhaps
Eddie it is video games the place so you
gotta think about it
cultivate the culture yeah it's on us to
anyway it's always been on us to
eliminate that stigma right to death to
you know move no you know widely
accepted now that it's you'd almost be
out of place if you were trying to poke
on somebody for playing games right you
would sound you would sound good sound
out of place completely out of place out
of touch out of time completely because
it's just it's such a norm in today's
society so I'm glad I'm glad for that
I'm glad that we're the ones that
step forward we're gonna give my sick
rollin like yeah how difficult is its I
think it what sold two million copies
already yeah it's actually it's the
highest selling of the fastest selling
from June from gaming in the company's
history and I I always felt that was
gonna be the case with that game just
because like I said the ninja stuff man
you know the aesthetics for sure that it
sure like it just it had people
interested in that game that are not
necessarily from software game fans and
just willing to take a shot on it right
maybe some of them fell off after they
purchased because they felt it was too
difficult or whatever the case may be
but for me I think that's what besides
the combat it's the aesthetic that keeps
us having a pan I mean that's I mean I
mean that's very appealing I think a lot
of people dig that that background that
setting of the game and you know it this
2090 so far you know we're getting close
to III I know we talked about that
earlier I mean it's been it's been a
great year so far I mean Devil May Cry 5
Capcom knocking out the park yeah don't
worry - yeah Resident Evil and chrome
was dead they were in 2016 they want and
they did it and they didn't he came back
on the strength of their old franchises
they really haven't necessarily you know
come back with anything super brand new
but they they realized that there was a
level of polish in their old games that
gamers appreciate and if you go back to
the formula it work you know if you
really put the effort you know it's it's
working Hollywood why you know why
working gaming and it boy I mean it I
think it's evident it works in gaming
now ya know so I you know I'm I'm all
for like I I'm okay I'm hoping Konami
goes I'm coming aboard for real man I'd
like to see a remake of Metal Gear Solid
the original on the line of Resident -
that's what they should do well this we
still don't know what uh how about a
Castlevania though let's see that and
that's another thing right when we get
one that's really good we forget about
all that bad yeah right really think
about that because a lot of those
remakes a lot of stuff that was coming
through it was bad it was
or poorly implemented we want the same
level of care that the Resident Evil 2
came through with right because it was
done right yeah look good it played very
well it was done right so us the the
guys that played at first can appreciate
it a little bit more than you know a new
person that's getting this game that the
game looks good what about this games
that came before there were piss-poor
right so we we don't know then this goes
into attics remake out with that yeah he
needs to get here um to talk about what
that thing is gonna do with that a final
fantasy so yeah addict I don't know
what's up he hasn't even answered any uh
messages or anything so I think he's
folded for the day but we may get him
you know build real quick shout out to
restored Hades with the two dollar super
chat I want a bloody roar reboot yes
bloody roar who did it too right yeah I
saw it recently
that's not look it didn't it didn't age
well but it was a great game it was
PlayStation 1 a PlayStation 2 well there
was no that was ps2 with the I think
there was a ps1 version and then for the
first one and then but the following
another ps2 and beyond developers was
aiding like eight with ing at the end
and Hudson soft soft yeah my god the
island yeah right I'm sold this is a
perfect today cuz we're all okay
I am gonna say this though it has been a
very exciting 2019 for gaming as a whole
I mean look we I know that I say it I've
gone on record saying at many at least
for the last two or three years
consecutively that it this is the best
year in gaming you know you look back to
2007 right and that was that's still
considered like the
the Dali Lama if you will of the game of
the gaming universe
it really was a you got so many amazing
games in 2007 it every year that has
passed gaming is trying to hit that you
know that that 2007 status with with
what we've seen in 2019 first of all it
has proven a lot of things to a lot at
least to me first of all the first
quarter of the year has normally been
dry as a desert and it has been proved
in fact that it is a great time to
release your game we've seen ridiculous
amounts of tile people up people are
still trying to figure out how can they
afford all of these games let alone play
them all and like I said if you're if
you're into gaming it doesn't matter
what flag if fly if you if you actually
if you can if you can afford to do it
not everyone can gaming is an expensive
hobby if you can afford to support all
three companies by buying their consoles
and playing the games that you love it
totally eliminates the console war
nonsense that goes on on social media it
really does you don't have to be
involved you can say well you know what
this this particular box is where I play
the most but I also have the other two
and I enjoy them as well you know what
console war over boom are you saying
that finances dictate you know what you
started I can't even say you don't know
it you know what you start we've been on
the same mind wave yes very long time
very long I we're talking and we're
talking uh you know grandfather days
like bloody was right there for who's
that don't want to do see that bloody
roar it's there put it so maybe you can
check it out um yeah just like boom said
you know on financially you tie yourself
to a horse basically and you want the
hello spoon in the race you want it to
come in first because everybody wants to
belong to something greater correct
yeah right and and it's nice I mean some
some guys scraped together than $300 for
that system and they're betting their
hopes and dreams that all the
multi-platinum we have first good first
party games and that stuff means a lot
to them to other guys that are a little
bit more financially affluent we go out
and we purchase every of anything when
it hits yeah well and we don't get you
know like we're actually really moving
in that fashion that we want to tech
we're technology hoarders so we wanted
the new technology we want to play the
new games with the new fidelity for
whatever reason it is and we are the
early afters that push the industry
forward but you guys are the lifeblood
who one system can only afford one
system only have time for one system and
I understand your allegiance is tied to
something that you're financially tied
to but don't debt agreat and don't push
down somebody else who did use in your
same position yes
that's what my issue is like a lot of it
comes from I I've seen a lot of the
arguments come from not necessarily you
you know bigging up what's good about
your system it's about putting down the
other one what the hell is that about
like it just doesn't make any sense like
because a lot of times if you are that
person who's on one console then you
don't really have a true understanding
of what's going on on the other side of
the fence so right so a lot of a lot of
the arguments bait behind it is there's
nothing objective there it's just pure
you know just you know running somebody
something to the coals just for the sake
of doing it it doesn't make any sense to
me in the records but boom you can
attest to this when we went to the
playground and that one kid that had a
Super Nintendo and the other kids had a
Genesis well his house happen to be the
new house that we were going to oh it
wasn't hated it was like yo how can we
hang out bro
I friends at turbografx-16 I'm like yo
let me go over there walks a venture
like that dude was the most exciting
dude in your team right everyone had
like Genesis at the time like me growing
up like if I think about the 16-bit era
everyone most everyone had Genesis then
when the you know turbo graphics 16 came
out SNES came out like we all would just
like we didn't care we like oh we gotta
go to that dudes house okay yeah SNES so
he's got turbo graphics or if you had
that one person or at the NeoGeo King
hello yeah that was actually had both I
had the cartridge and the CD and the CD
we are both yeah I was talking about
that a few weeks ago how we had the the
samurai shodown on CD and we were
waiting for it since
oh yeah I can't wait to get to LA with
boom because let me tell you let me tell
you why I'm like what its gonna be like
Joe Pesci and all sorts of me we're
twins don't don't ever get it twisted
listen to what he says right and then
just hit a voice then put my voice on
what he's saying like Brody did you see
boom statue yo shout out to boom right
did you see his amiibos oh yeah vivo
game is lit right my favorite unboxing
or what you did what was it the UH
Disick here oh no the helmet oh I didn't
yes I was I had went out and I purchased
the fallout 76 collector's edition and I
and I was very public about I'm buying
it for the collector's editions helmet
not the game cuz I didn't expect much
from the game if I would have enjoyed
the game it would have been a bonus I'm
a big fan of fallout
I have the pip-boy I have the lunchbox
from the original collector you know
from the original og collector's edition
I have everything so
you know I did the unboxing and you know
I thought it was gonna be kind of cool
to finish off the video by wearing the
helmet so what I did is I put the helmet
on and I got somehow got the microphone
that I was wearing on my head into the
microphone Oh God but what I didn't not
realize is that the air wasn't gonna get
into that helmet as well so I had to
take a deep breath I did to take about a
dozen times before I got it right and
I'm not gonna sit here and lie to you by
the time I was done when you see you
don't see it because obviously it's
edited I was feeling a bit woozy after
wearing that helmet because I did it and
the take kids of the last day came out
perfect but but there was at least 11
other takes prior that I was like okay I
lift up the helmet tickles it okay and I
do my spiel and I had to shorten because
I'm running out of breath in this thing
so I wound up having them okay welcome
thanks for tuning doble gaming and it
kind of sounded like I was speeding up a
few times I got to do it again the
extent of boom was willing to go to
provide his product remember that if you
go like and subscribe box I'm gonna bend
over backwards for this community so
it's at least I can do
my worst part about it to possess the
fraud boxing was buggy okay so Lord
addict we have the young wolf of the ILP
in the difficult game conqueror dude did
you finish that girl yet no oh you suck
you messing up my intro you killing me
you killing me wait how close to you I I
can't really say how close I am let's
just say close alright wrestle what's
going on man besides being under the
table was good nothing this is the
Sakura game and it's it's it's it's
testing my patience this is addictive it
is addictive
yo ya'll guys heard it right I've really
um I'm advising against this it's so 2
million minus 1
might is it because I little it's like I
said last week like I like being able to
just dodge and like this game it's like
we don't care what you like you gonna
play it our way yeah you're gonna marry
you're not gonna die because once you
start dodging they adjust to that and no
matter how far away you try to dodge
they will get you so I sometimes you'll
try to like sidestep that's worth than
every from software game and it's like
the blade just extends just a little bit
yes it hits you that's the worst feeling
ever he's it's the most frustrating
thing I'm like when inside ok pretty
much like since your messages guy I told
you what told you a blog oh yeah it's
happening with me wide sidestep
basically at an angle and I end up
almost behind the dude
I fought him once I'm pretty sure you
fight him twice is horrifying but I love
it like I love every second if you don't
if you don't want before we move on to
the next topic and I just want to just
do a quick channel update and give the
people the heads-up first of all if you
missed the Xbox Factor podcast this week
you missed a good one because I was able
to score Brad Samms from Thoreau calm
and let me tell you something not only
is that man a gentleman he is wickedly
smart I mean that way when you say Xbox
insider that dude he just doesn't know
about Xbox he knows everything there is
to know about Microsoft but you know he
dropped some real dope knowledge about a
battle royale mode that he has heard is
going to be in the new Halo and a lot of
a few other little tidbits in there you
know he says nothing's confirmed but
this is what he's hearing so you know
obviously it's probably just gonna be a
mold like war zone or big teeth and it's
a shame that a lore
neither's night here so I can so I can
sit and discuss that would be coming off
every it's just it's just probably gonna
be a mode it's not gonna be if it's not
gonna be featured Buddy Walk it's the
new pub G he won't even try
apex legends right yeah game is good
again it's not my type again I'm not a
big PR guy but I did play it I did enjoy
it and and then this week this upcoming
week I I you know it's crazy that how
you know you go from trying to get
people on and obviously Enrique was
talking about it sometimes it's it's a
lot you know there's a lot of ladders to
climb to get someone on the show I was
able to to get Ryan Roth who is the
audio director for void bastards he's
gonna be on the show for an hour I've
already sent him the questions
everything is good and it's gonna be a
real amazing episode at this week's Xbox
factor podcast he's doing it man really
I couldn't be happier for you man you
you were like the hardest working dude
he's really out there appreciate I was
not kidding when I said I need to take a
drink before I start on your intro
because it's like it's a whole bunch of
stuff man and and I know you I know
there are more opportunities out there
for you and you just you know you're
kind of you know leveling yourself off a
little bit because you don't want spread
yourself too thin but it's insane man
but you really well I mean I gotta be
honest so you know the real you know the
real bucket list check that's probably
the size of the paper that it's on is
the III and that's and that's really
thanks to you guys that that's thanks to
two of kognito to King to everyone
that's on this panel uh you know I had
no idea you know where to even start
you know or to you know to put my foot
on a path for the journey for III and
you know you guys kind of just really
laid it down for me and you know I just
father's follow the steps and you know
again it's it's it's not cheap folks if
you want to get to III you know you got
to make some sacrifices and which I've
done I've done a significant amount of
that I mean sometimes games have to be
put on the back burner that aren't
important to make this happen but I I'm
hoping to score a bunch of interviews
and I'm going to be
live from e3 coverage every day like
it's gonna be fun my wife laughs can I
told her like this is really a work trip
she's like yeah right you're hanging out
with King and those guys it's gonna be
work but it's gonna be fun
boom I get that all the time and I first
first shoutout to Ricardo Willis at a
great show with two great guests Lord
King great king of statues thank you so
much
I hope Lynda Carter you know hears you
that that was a it was a love letter for
me to her you know um and the movement
that she was about for that king of
statues I don't think that statue eight
is indicative of what you're gonna get
this week but you're gonna get this week
coming is my first custom statue that
I've purchased isn't it strange
China I've never seen anyone posted I've
never seen anyone unbox it and I'm going
to unbox and I'm going to post it and I
want that one to do what Lords of gaming
that Annette is doing to reviews and
interviews and stuff like that now I
want it to be felt I want you to feel it
you know custom statue on the back that
you had I have it spread out to read
tighten my brothers in England whose
link me to because that when I start to
explain that world to you guys later
it's there's a lot of community ties and
a lot of leaning on somebody's work you
send your money out to say that 100 out
there hmm you're waiting six seven
months for your statue to get made and
you're just hoping that year six you
just you know seven hundred dollars or
whatever that you sent his is validated
and is only validated when that statue
comes all right but once you get into
the community and then you know who all
the charlatans and who who you Brussels
right that's a huge thing so um
hopefully I can shed a lot of light on
that
for you guys a lot of people don't want
to give out their sources I understand
that stuff and you get vetted you get
better I got vetted this week by one of
my idols um Alex from rat tight and
please go follow likes and subscribe
they they show a lot and they helped me
along my journey and I hopefully I can
help you guys along your journey um to
achieve your level of comfortability now
my level of comfortability that's why I
do different levels of statues it's not
about $3,000 statues or $100 statues
it's about what you want you know that
that everybody has an inner drive right
so when I say king of statues your house
is your statues like boom is the king of
his statues so it's not just about me
being the king of statues it's about you
guys empowering you guys to get out and
do so thank you so much for the final
switch I do really appreciate it and
yeah I just put that up there for
display for y'all so y'all can see go do
that go get it you know Cain I want to
just kind of touch on what you're saying
when we get onto the topic so if that's
okay yeah I I haven't I have a custom
Arkham Batman that was 500 bucks and it
is it is one-of-a-kind I think there are
only three I think from what I
understand there are only three of them
available I own one of them one of them
has broken so technically there's only
two and I I will I wish I will show I
actually will take pictures and I'll
send it in the DM the one thing about
customs he's right you know you got to
be real careful because you're these
people are taking your money so you got
to be you know you know I paid for I've
hunted before I even had a product and I
was I'm not gonna sit in line and say it
wasn't nervous because that's 500 I'll
that's a lot of money but when you get
that statue home and you put it up and
it's you know that there's only a
handful of these things out and when you
take pictures people oh my god what can
I get the front mop sorry my friend this
is a custom there's only three available
and I own one of them I'm sorry I've
been I've been offered 1500 for this
statue from people and it's not going
anywhere it's not because it's worth
more than that to you because it's a pro
surfer so I'm a huge Batman
fan love him because he's he's all all
Batman is is a human being who uses his
detective skills and his wits and you
know how vicious he is as a fighter and
that's what makes him one of the best
heroes out there because he's just human
I tell you I I really appreciate what
you guys do I wish I still had that
drive to collect physical things I used
to and for whatever reason it just
whatever fellow you marry now bro yeah I
can't because my kids want to grab all
this my car early you see those steps
out of the basement yeah the basement is
lava
I have amiibo's in the boxes my kids
want to unbox I'm like hey could you
imagine you come home and all your
amiibos is unbox and they just miss
playing they just look at gee I actually
kick I had that happen once already and
I was let me tell you something man that
Latin temper almost came out they don't
throw shoes at him I want to grab a
chunk leather and throw it seriously you
don't want the junk wet that hitting you
brother that pinpoint accuracy you don't
want my mom my mom was like Peyton
Manning throwing chocolate sauce not a
game not a game so let's get into these
topics it's open all day and that's
talked about gaming at all and this is
actually my topic so yesterday Respawn
Entertainment finally unveiled Jedi
fallen order they're brand new
third-person action game in the Star
Wars universe so I want to know what you
guys what you guys think of what you saw
from the trailer it was just a teaser
trailer I didn't show a lot but it gave
you an idea of what the story is where
in the timeline it happens afterwards we
did get some clarification of like what
type of game it is
whatnot so what do you guys think even
more generally what do you guys think
about everything that got set is Star
Wars Celebration the teaser for episode
9 and then we'll get into what we
thought about the game so let's start
with Lord boom let's see what what's
your Star Wars love like well first of
all I can say that I saw Star Wars in
the theater in 1978 with my mom and dad
and I have been a fan ever since yes I'm
an old-school cat and you know what um
okay you know episode 8 you know left a
lot left a lot of people sour and I hear
it I I'm not a fan of that director JJ
Abrams in my opinion knocked it out of
the park though it was safe in the first
you know episode 7 it was safe but it
was it was a great return to what made
Star Wars great and episode 9 is coming
and on the heels of that we have now
respawn you know who are the creators of
titanfall 1 and titanfall 2 both
fantastic titles but what people forget
about Vince Zampella and the team at
respawn is that those guys and gals
we're responsible for the good Call of
Duty games ok and I'm not and I really
mean that
I really mean all of Duty has fallen off
a cliff for me personally especially
when you start talking about you know
the storm every row here there's no such
thing as a good Call of Duty to differ
I beg to differ if you go back to call
of duty modern warfare you know for and
you go and you and one after that that
was I enjoyed all that raises that was
it was overhyped well I mean that again
everyone's entitled to their opinion but
my point is is that you know they are
good storytellers and how you know that
for a fact is if you play titanfall 2
single-player campaign which was
magnificent probably one of the best
this generation yeah um and now we see
this teaser trailer and of course that's
what it is is a trailer but at the same
time we you know III think what has many
people not talk
about is that we're getting a
single-player focused story driven
narrative that's canon within the Star
Wars universe it has been confirmed that
there's no microtransactions I love that
immediately throw it out there it's EA
so you never know right you're like okay
yeah I'm I'm taking a breath but they
are the first and here's the other thing
it's running on Unreal Engine 4 as
opposed to frostbite which is what
ruined and is still ruining anthem thank
ya I can I can imagine the roar of from
the crowd yes like something they said
that something's with like respond if
that's what they have power over there
like it's like oh oh we making this
free-to-play we we doing this now oh
wait we a use in frostbite got shafted
as much as they got shafted we would
titanfall to release agent that they
should have that bomb they should have
the cloud for sure so I'm gonna be
honest with you I'm very excited for
this game I know that it's up digitally
to pre-order which of course I'm gonna
get the maximum edition but I'm holding
off in the hopes that there is some sort
of a collector's edition it comes with a
statue because obviously like the King
here I am a big fan of statues as a
matter of fact if I'm not sure if you
guys saw yesterday I sent it to King I
have a statue of the the actual order
from the film saying or you know eggs
you know or you know order 66
yes order 60 squares he's holding a
hologram of the emperor in this hand and
that's one of my favorite pieces in
that's a six hundred and fifty dollar
piece that's that's it's probably
tripled that by now I'm a huge Star Wars
fan the little mini busts
I have 86 of them oh and I have
something I have yes I actually I want
to get you know I don't have a man cave
yet so I had to kind of trade those for
the amiibos but those may be coming back
because like I said those are super
expensive those are made by gentle giant
obviously the King knows who they are
because they they're great but this
particular game I got if look I'm gonna
say this first of all episode 9 looks
amazing this do the trailer for this
game looks amazing and what they were
talking about in regards to what
Disney's gonna be doing with the
franchise and it would you know
with the Star Wars Celebration if you
are Star Wars fan
you got you got bucket loads of
information and I'm excited nothing that
they said disappointed me yeah dad
that's for sure I know there were people
that you know like the naming
conventions for the movie the rise of
Skywalker and obviously anybody is not a
spoiler but at the end of the at the end
of the trailer you're Palpatine's voice
and they're like what the heck is what's
going on here
like what why the last the last movie in
the Skywalker saga we have you know
force ghosts bad force ghosts good force
ghosts what's going on so honestly like
I'm excited just to see how wacky could
get and I hope it closes things out well
but uh Oh Brad what do you think about
this man you just are worth it uh yes I
am a Star Wars fan did not see Star Wars
the movie theaters in 1977 I think you
know that's awesome boom that's awesome
you had that experience I 77 yes I think
corrected yeah that's that's awesome and
I mean to have that experience you know
I um I was I don't like the name rise
the Skywalker's um but that's you know
it is what it is I mean it will probably
find out obviously we'll find out why
they named in the movie that you know
after we watch it but I'm just look you
know the with with response game and the
trailer and everything I just I'm so
excited for anything and everything Star
Wars right now I will say this like the
video has to have dirt on someone a TA
like because he have a video of someone
saying something or someone doing
something they should have done because
he is basically like calling the shots I
think addict said like we're not doing
frostbite like that's not happening you
know you know we're not gonna do
remember transactions remember in the
meeting with Vince they're like do you
think has a hundred percent back your
back he's like whatever that means
he's got swag he's like you know what
he's like hey you know what I'm
untouchable I'm excited
what it is I don't think it was but I
think when you know their game started
flopping more and more not necessarily
flopping just not making as much money
uh uh and you know they've always had
critically-acclaimed gains but it hasn't
had the cells like yeah he's like we
gotta do something different it was like
get cuz if you think about it they're a
relatively new acquired studio and they
gave them a Star Wars game yeah
and they allow this make it it's like
the equivalent of giving something like
like well obviously not talent wise but
it's like giving like Ninja Theory a
Star Wars game but what you have to
understand is that their quality shows
so when you'll say oh he has kar blonde
she has cachet what other development
house inside DEA has a name that you can
sit then you can follow Oh
what other development house in EA has
that level of cachet that's going to be
names don't buy wear though I mean like
my words like I think by with the dead
today so you had a helping hand with
that but I'm just saying when it comes
along to that I believe Bioware were
playing it loose and free and they're
gonna come together and do some little
Bioware sauce at the end now now take x
can your parents tell you all the time
stop you know your homework right before
you gotta go to school
stop stop doing your homework in the
morning it's gonna catch up to you wanna
pull up to them bro what I was over in
twos you know they were forced at hand
when it come to what engine they use
yeah yeah they actually said that they
put them they push them in the direction
of anthem but they didn't give them any
kind of landscaping
the secret ninja
gaagh not telling you what you want to
hear what you need to hear what we need
to hear is there might be a battle
royale for halo right I had to jump it a
little bit take some pain medication
where this is good discussion I was
listening to boom and a minute same page
with him as far as this because it's
like with Zampella one thing about him a
respawn the track record is strong man I
guess really strong so I'm very curious
to see what they're gonna do and um like
like like boom said with the whole co D
like the mono won't feel like people
don't realize like halo was to go at
that point and when modern warfare King
everything shifted the original modern
warfare that's his baby so to see him do
that then we got titanfall you know I'm
saying and now you know with him again
free of frostbite kind of running his
own ship and I think he's got so much
leverage with with apex being a success
that it is they really can't tell him
anything you don't I'm saying so um yeah
I'm excited I'm excited to see where
we're respawn goes with it
I know me a fast is going ahead a little
bit Ortiz he's real nervous because EA
is involved but at the end of the day I
mean we got a look at his response
advocate respawn and like like like cog
said and like boom said it really it's
respawn but it really is old-school
Infinity Ward and also Ward had carte
blanche like do whatever you want
yeah a car blast with Activision so he's
used to working with those big ya know
publishers in the politics that that
that's involved working and being under
that that question at the end of the day
it's probably just like Lord King David
said like yeah what do you think the
most clout Studios the EA owns I would
say respawn and like that's all I Star
Wars K so like it's it's like the one
they gave everyone a Star Wars game but
the one they wanted that everyone wants
to have in star
which is Bioware so now I don't think
bio is in a position to do exactly what
we expect of them clean up until they go
to the dojo and a king a ton of people
I'm just to be given an RPG and be like
run with it you can't you don't know if
you're gonna get late laws gone I mean
Michael no lies in the practices in the
beginning you know like shard it was
complete leadership like they dropped
the ball in multiple different ways yeah
stop trying to at the end trying to sew
everything together that's the whole
thing is like if if you have to build a
different pedigree it's like when you
tear down a basketball team or football
team and you're starting from the farm
system that's awesome throw him under
the bus
whatever is like I thought he was I
didn't think he was right for the job
anyway um but when you you have to start
things you have to build a culture if
the culture is already toxic in there
and then you think at the end achar
gonna come together and rally it's a
squad and no it's not gonna happen in
that manner so if he decided that
frostbite was a detriment and it has to
get out of here for in order for this to
be made great because he put out apex
and listen apex is the only thing
pushing for tonight right now so we have
to leave him alone it's a game right now
yes yeah and it's not use the Frostbite
ages think about that part like they've
been trying to force-feed people this
frostbite engine to save some bucks in
the corner yeah so much tax yet I think
that was at a detriment to a lot of
these game I think anthem could have
been a 10 times better game had there
been on Unreal Engine yeah I mean a lot
of these these little boardroom
decisions guys that we're not privy to
hurt our development houses and don't
have a word they can't say we're not
gonna use this engine if they tell you
make this
game and use this engine and here's your
money then this is what they have to do
so now I mean the biggest thing I got
from that whole thing was we're using
Unreal Engine mm-hmm and that right
there was the boom and kickin what that
means it means it's exclusive to the
epic story something about that coming
up but I'm surprised nobody's talked
about what my affinity for this is and
as soon as I see third-person action
Jedi battles lightsaber battles I don't
think I enjoyed the Force Unleashed
games on the 360 I thought they were
great I thought they were cool
I thought that all the powers and stuff
were excellently implemented but I go
back to the old genies dark forces the
Jedi Outcast
yes Jedi Knight like to me it's you know
obviously doesn't have that first-person
element that then turned into that sort
of over-the-shoulder third-person
element but those games especially Jedi
Outcast and then Jedi Academy afterwards
they the essence of the the Jedi was
there like everything from the force
powers to how you deflected like lasers
and stuff like that with your with the
with the lightsaber
it was all there and to me that's what
I'm most excited about in this game they
do have they touted that right yeah you
know something one thing that I thought
was cool from Washington trailer was
that the main protagonist is like he
doesn't want to show that he's force
sensitive but he has a bit he has to
allocate and so like like that sets up
this dynamic like this like from a
storytelling perspective like there's
just internal struggle with him like you
know what like I know I have this like
like yeah I'm force sensitive I have
these powers but I can't show them but I
want to do good I want to help people
but I can and so there's like that the
eternal conflict where I think it was
really cool that we got to see a little
bit of that I think it gives us a little
more insight into what happens after to
the dogs yeah
what happens after order 66 you know
because I mean we we we do know about
over 66 after like if you've read you
know like some of the novels and stuff
stories novels
but if you haven't you know this this
games with even more insight into that
which is to me fascinating and and one
of the things that I'm really excited
about and the one thing I'll say to
visually the game looks I felt great
from what we saw that's that trailer and
I'm excited I'm excited I would say this
I think ray is probably the most badass
jet I've ever seen in my life she did a
flip over a spaceship we talked about
that she Park or dive whoa wait a bit
like like she did a flip yeah I'm
interested to see what they do with that
character cuz they said I mean they said
every every generation has a legend so
they're there they're propping her up as
that
what's up she's the most powerful Jedi
I'm Eve you think we've never seen a
Jedi do a flip over a spaceship about
that I mean he's probably coming at her
what Borden Mach 1 speed I guess our
killer destroyed whole that's true that
is true I mean literally that's the one
out of space and record okay that's true
and I did it Thanos with it like he
grabbed it and Chuck that I remember
that yeah
so I tell you like for me what's
interesting is how do they handle
because he's a he's a pod one right he's
actually a Padawan that that survived
order 66 so by that definition he was
forced you know he had the
midi-chlorians in him you know he was
the script in the middle or Ian's made
their way into this but the thing is
with episode 8 they sort of read console
and said okay anybody can be for
sensitive now it's not necessarily
anybody that you know that that we can
sense this in and then we take them and
train them and show them how to use that
for sensitivity you know really you
didn't like the fact that anybody could
be a Jedi Knight to be stupid I don't
like that I found that to be absolutely
stupid um I thought that you supposed to
find it in the children
I thought they they were supposed to
show our affluence in the force and I
thought that not everybody was the same
like the little mutants so the fact that
anybody this is like everybody get a
trophy what you're saying basically is
that the participation trophy ideology
has gone all the ways of the future I
disagree I know I think I think it shows
that not that you don't have to have the
name Skywalker to be force sensitives
everyone that just wants to be is not
cold
the funny thing is Skye like you know
Luke was supposed to be like something
that didn't happen often like you know
yeah yeah when they came around hundreds
and hundreds of thousands of years and
like I'm product faceting about raised
characters that she seems like Oh Felix
compared to Luke she to me she seems
more powerful to Luke right and I and I
think the fact the fact that they I
don't think they're red conning the
whole that she's like she doesn't come
from any sort of lineage right so
they're not they're leaving that so I
think if you look at the marketing
departments was just a walker
yeah no and that's the thing is she is
Skywalker or she's there to be a dance
kind of if she is not a Skywalker they
say she's a wookie woke up I know
at a point right now like I don't I
don't I I believe in winners and losers
okay
why not honestly I honestly believe in
that I believe that on a basketball
court
somebody's gonna win if somebody's gonna
lose some I don't know a whole let out
and you have a water there's the trophy
- no I don't I'm tired of that
everybody gets off you know everybody's
not a Jedi bro you are not a Jedi it's a
special gene and if you ain't got it
you get thrown over though Mary made you
think that one dude was a main character
and then they just face them I don't
like the fact that they they're showing
that you don't have to be a Skywalker to
be like this awesome like I get that but
between you know the massacre that the
Jedi's took there's not many people and
many bloodlines that could be that
powerful and now they have an every one
be that powerful I don't think they said
everyone though I mean they sure that
kid at the end of the last episode of
you know was a force sensitive and that
was his there was only when you see
somebody who's never picked up a
lightsaber go toe-to-toe with with a
Shogun assassin turn Jedi Knight like
what like the story that Disney's doing
with this no you guys go you guys gonna
really hate you for this man I'd rather
play a role
was episode six probably like seven it
was I was done a rehash it was just it
was all its native horrible like they
breed people first left they don't
answer half the questions they give you
then they put people in the show in the
movie that they haven't even really
talked about mmm it showed up all that
that's the do that's doing up then you
have a a Jedi Master that's supposed to
be equivalent to Yoda doesn't notice
that the forces being used to his right
like I don't get it quick shout out to
the chat force and Christopher Hart
apparently Tiger Woods is back on top
again
god bless thank you
shout out needed to do was go back to
his infidelities and money man you know
it's great how about you watch this now
he's actually walking down with his son
which is actually just what would Swami
what it would a picture moment knew I
was watching it early on and he was down
I think four strokes and they were
saying that the guy that was a top was
really just unbelievable the fact that
Tiger came back to witness it just goes
to show you that the talent that that
dude has is crazy good he's been
battling injuries to bull yes yes sure
he has with those especially yes knees
is back mean he's but the last I feel
like the last two years he's kind of
been knocking at the door you know
in better and better after yeah William
major maybe maybe maybe Tigers
force-sensitive
wait oh wait dad with that last comment
let's move on to the next let me get let
me get some love I might could only be
for like about two days one if we could
switch to order cuz I definitely want to
touch on that control I know that and
then the second thing is on some hot off
the press I don't know if you saw the
Eurogamer article yeah let's go let's go
like yeah the report just came out from
your gamer and apparently Jason sure I
was on a recent episode of split screen
podcast and he made a comment he's
talked about you know how destiny 2
would fare Post Bungie separation from
Activision and he intimated that while
Bungie had been keen to make character
transfer a reality its exclusivity
partnership with Sony prevented the
developer from pressing ahead he said
that I heard Bungie wanted to do
character transfers for ps4 and PC
before Forsaken came out he said but
Sony wouldn't allow it
Shriya said sony is like we want people
to associate destiny with yet or even if
that means screwing over other players
so i was this was this is mind-boggling
to me because obviously you know attic
and i go back with this we was one of
the strangest exclusivity deals we've
ever seen in the history of gaming and
yeah and now vision thing is gonna be
ending we know right now there's a
current bug right now where I believe
Xbox guys and PS are PC guys are in yes
with an exclusive gun exotic called the
way you did your Smurfs did they just
rocked it they locked it out so we know
we're under the impression that come
September and shout the hold law he's
the one that but he actually told us
this way back when I'll Pete when that
was gonna happen
so that when the Activision deal
officially is ended and that new content
comes out in September you know that
deal looks like it's gonna be dissolved
so what do you guys feel about
you know Sony really stopping
cross-platform and cross progression
with this move it just goes to show you
the de not for the players and at their
full of s sorry X I'm sorry I mean it
here's the thing every game before I
want you going to sector then I know you
you know listen we talked earlier above
the console uh nonsense and how to avoid
it right and we know that everyone could
be you know can afford it if the game is
expensive and I completely understand
that but when you see these Sony players
and you know who I'm talking about I'm
not naming names I'm saying that there
is a very significant large very nasty
very dominant very toxic Sony community
that they thought about big man that
Sony is is indeed powering forward for
the players and this this is bombshell
this is this is this is a this is
another I mean listen I'm gonna be
honest with you I don't know Jason
Schreyer I know that he digs sometimes
he says things he's not supposed to say
this is back-to-back bombshells from
this guy so he obviously has explained
it I mean everyone knows that he is the
go-to guy and when he says something
publicly 99.9% of the time it's true
he's got yeah he's massive contact and
for good reason the guy the guy is a
good reporter there's no doubt about it
regardless of my feelings and this is
bombshell and this is this is again guys
I want you to understand we're just cut
this article right that cog was talking
about it kind of just peel back a little
bit but there's something that's gonna
happen post of this article and what I
believe is gonna happen
is that with Sony not having any
information out this year for their
players no III cancelled PSX cancelled
you know shows in 2018 nothing proven
for 2019 except four days gone which by
the way if you guys didn't know and
we're gonna talk about this week slip
into Tony it's funny
no no it's coming out it's coming out
but the problem is is that the
the the the review is not going to be
made available to the public until until
the 25th when the game launches in
twenty six to me that screams issues and
it has been a proven fact that that that
does happen
Sony has and they look at the name
changes the name changes are supposed to
be a good thing and now you're starting
to hear that people losing trophies they
can't start their game I mean it's it's
always a no slip yeah maybe it's Tony I
don't know this this is this goes to
show you that Sony does not really care
about their player base these are me gay
take it away I got I got I got a brother
I love saying they're not as bad as you
think guys and yo I feel you because you
don't want to believe that your idols
are monster all right and listen
god bless good luck um but we all knew
that Sony was blocking situations and it
just came out and I was out alright so
but I do love your fandom and I do
respect the brother and I'm glad you had
week the whole that way anyway I don't
wanna I'm gonna start off my little rant
real quick with what he just said when
Xbox wants to make beneficial moves for
their own purposes y'all say nothing no
that's not true the issue I have is when
you are 8a when you are Sony and you're
matcha is we're for the gamers and you
do [ __ ] like this excuse my language
you're not for the gamers you're for
yourself mmm you are for yourself you
are not doing anything to benefit the
gaming community when you say we want
people to associate destiny with ps4
even it means screwing other players
that is terrible Sony have you not
learned for your mistakes for
PlayStation 3 I'm telling you guys I
wouldn't be surprised if next console
generation if the Xbox is the leader mmm
the next gen we
that out of her arrogance because of
arrogant weight they do that all the
time you say flip-flop it like what you
winning the next is amazing
that's hubris it happens but King
porcine that humor so we're seeing it
again main changes the name changes the
cross play you know what Charlotte said
all sites we're okay with cross play you
know we we we all developer has to do is
ask us and the developer came out Africa
developer that's not true yeah yeah so
my thing was and this was the biggest
red flag and you know let you go do it
no the backing away from your fans okay
now when you back away from your fans
from III okay let's say all right fine
we're gonna back away from the fence
backing oh I think that's the most
disrespectful thing they've done in
years disrespectful but this is where I
thought knew it was serious when you
back away from your multi-platform
partners from displaying their wares on
a stage and you have promotional rights
to these games I you know you you have
exclusivity deals with multipel
multi-platform games first and they also
launched first on your system there to
promote said game I have noticed that
like we we got stuff like Kingdom Hearts
day and day like it's like they're
losing that that vantage point when it
comes to getting stuff on their platform
first okay to page on oh what's up
shout out to Philly Eagle for the second
super tattle Eagle always represent both
math words only there's the same thing
that epic is doing now yes they have
some games but many of those bangers
aren't made by Sony proper they are so
yeah that's facts that is the sound of
five not made by them
Nick neo not made by them I get that
they're also the market leader that's
why they're gonna get those those deals
but I think if you if your mantra is for
the gamers
this has been for since 2013 yep the
part that like live by that you know I
mean and mad shout out to Jason's fire
by the way yeah this is back-to-back
bombshell yeah new stories dude I mean
it's he again he's I don't know if he's
gonna win any awards for it but he's
certainly definitely opening up doors
we're definitely not yeah but yeah but
that's that's up that's my biggest issue
and if it's always been my issue with
Sony like their mantras always been for
the gamers but then the new stuff that's
for the gamers don't do stuff like this
that's terrible yeah that is in terrible
let me think about that that message we
wouldn't you don't care we just want we
want it on our platform but I get it
like you're a business you want to make
money
mm-hmm but if you if you're if your
marketing mantra is dead then you don't
believe that you know what really what
it shows me Dobrev which goes to show in
my opinion the power of fortnight like
fortnight was able to buck that trend
with them and they couldn't deny the
cross play and they couldn't deny to
cross progression because of how big of
an entity it was and how much backlash
they received that III so it's
interesting man because now that this
thing is free you know hopefully buns
you should be able to move forward and
and able to allow CrossFit imagine at
this cross progression on PC Xbox if
there's another like another battle.net
what is PC if go go get something with
them like but it's just hot place but it
would have to allow it that's the next
thing but yeah man it's interesting to
see I thought this was a huge news and
always wanted to know behind the scenes
and it seems like finally that
information came out there yeah Sony was
not trying too loud they wanted it to be
associated with the PlayStation brand
and they didn't they didn't care about
screwing anybody they wouldn't even let
Microsoft market the first one like they
weren't allowed to yeah they have like a
little Cologne advertisements yeah or
even alone
they weren't even allowed just to say it
was out for their platform mm-hmm
there's like like the Destiny Cologne
remember that yes yes because they could
do it and that's so it's ridicu
you think about it that's horrible like
what how did we get that know that's
that's business now not to even let them
say it's out for the right don't let we
will not acknowledge you sir I'm down
see that part right there I'm down with
that whole bully tactics
I'm down with Sony on listen they got
they bunch with and you know what they
did they said then say okay okay they
think is a joke they thinking game right
because of their hubris coming into ps3
I feel like we're starting to see this a
little bit 360 everybody this is nothing
like missing sovereign said it before I
think they go in the back room and see
you listen I'm gonna mess up big time
this way use like it because you know
what's the thing is this some of the
mistakes Oh obvious snatch defeat from
the jaws of victory when you have it in
hand you know what I think they're gonna
do you know I think they're gonna mess
up uh uh you know people think they're
going to for some VR VR I don't think
they're necessarily gonna force VR you
know like the the extra components is
you need for the VR we have now right I
think they're gonna be they're gonna
build that into it where do you go and
that's gonna take thus if you want to
raise the price but you're gonna have to
they're gonna get like the extra stuff
for the VR and they're gonna build that
in naturally with the PS file what do
you think about the rumor that the next
psvr is Wireless super powerful yeah on
to Dayton the reason that is because
everything's built into the PS file
alright okay now here we go this is it
this is it I'm glad you want miss
disgusting
oh here we go alright so alright yes
it's gonna be in the box right your
joint is something that we didn't ask
for hold on who did that we see um xbox
one day there with the Kinect we didn't
care for that box okay no they just told
you they bacon it into the system okay
so they're gonna make the actual
hardware
I don't think that they're gonna force
you to buy yeah I don't think they're
forces that would kill it what I'm
saying
let's hear me first so you can say what
you gonna say because I know what you're
gonna say they're not putting the
headset in the box
no bro you pay for that there's no way
it's gonna be a $400 piece so listen
listen I I'm a supporter of PlayStation
VR I absolutely love it I talk about in
all my shows I love it so much that
because it didn't have HDR pass-through
on the first version I sold that one
privately and then Ari bought the new
version just so I can have HDR
pass-through I have about 40 of VR games
ok I don't play it a lot but I
absolutely love it
the wire thing is slightly annoying I
said it from the beginning PS 5 maximum
edition if there's only one out of
course I'll get it but if there's a
better Edition I'll get that and with
the with the VR headset if it's wireless
I'm saying 400 just to be fair but if
you remember psvr came out it was five
beans mm-hmm okay and that was with the
wire that was without all the extras
that was only with a demo disc and no
hgr pass-through so if you're gonna get
a wireless PlayStation VR which of
course I will have and will enjoy the
[ __ ] out of
pardon my french that is you're looking
at a 1k one grand purchase including any
games if you look at vive I've has a
$7.99 premium edition system that's
wireless and download everything to the
new vive this terminal yeah there you go
alright so that you saying that the
PlayStation is going to come in under
that I believe that the system is um
$4.99 right with the game and the
controllers right and I believe that's
going to be that that the end-all-be-all
when it comes to VR right they're
betting heavy here but my contingency
part is that they're baking this into
the system
alright on a silicon level not one
second shut up let's move with the $2 to
super check out let's y'all Thank You
kid much appreciate my brother loves
this talking about this into the system
right this is going to raise the cost in
an area that
has to be you have to offset that cost
no money I have to come from someplace
right this is going to be a powerful
system not saying that it won't be and
not to mention we're seeing like it like
crazy lucky controllers that looks like
it's genuine and it might be but now
this is where the flip-flop this is
where sovereigns theory comes into play
right and I mean and I believe him now I
honestly believe him but first I thought
he was just whistling past the graveyard
but because it has happened it had never
been a consecutive champion from one
generation to the next
no it has always been hubris before the
fall and never seen a level of hubris
no people are telling you ahead of time
we're not angry
yes when the ps/2 don't think so I
really think so and just like what you
said I really didn't think so because I
thought the PlayStation was gaining that
ground and I thought drink has actually
won that battle my opinion yeah I can't
go to one that generation ps1 one the
generation before about the see that's
the thing
the Dreamcast is in between that whole
PlayStation 1 PlayStation 2 thing the
PlayStation 2 came out overtook it
mm-hmm right so that's where that that's
just my opinion on that but - I think
this is their fault
because they're not gonna be the most
powerful system we can all attest to
that I don't care what they're talking
about anacondas let's mash it in aid
right it's true so thank you back
there's gonna do yeah you see Microsoft
is gearing up to bash their forehead so
okay so now they're betting on you guys
who is going to bring a library forward
like an apple type of thing didn't care
about you before which you bring in your
library forward but they saw how
beneficial it was for Xbox so III think
that's a plus for you guys right because
I really haven't brought anything did
you do with them because I was afraid
with Sony in particular Microsoft I
wasn't afraid because they showed that
digital stuff was caring so I wasn't
afraid with buying
I was listening the Cognito the whole
time I'm at first I was tell you I was
saying I'm doing that bro I'm did you
know I'm scared and he's like shut up
I'm doing all digital yeah III
acquiesced it what he was saying it was
right
Sony had me afraid now I see that
they're gonna move this stuff forward I
can buy a little bit more digital stuff
and I see they notice a benefit but you
can't say the red flags aren't there for
what's going to happen they're going to
lose the next battle and it goes yes I
will say there are some red flags coming
in as far as humorous as for that plenty
nice and I was a humorous yes I would
say I mean the times gonna tell that the
other day they still got the eyepiece
though I mean we do know they have the
horizon zero dawn too and you know
they're sitting on some mega names and
it's gonna be interesting to see how
they release it in the in the cadence
but as far as you know tear incognito to
your point about games I mean think
about something power I mean up until
this generation the most powerful
console hasn't always won exactly it's
always kind of games and look at the
tender look what nintendon't doing with
a less powerful console there's a game
but it also comes to the least common
denominator and that's price always yes
price yes yes that's very through an
operation a cheapo people listen because
if there was the same price as the big
boys that she would move hopefully like
I said they'd be able to resolve this
whole thing and Bungie get the
cross-platform going but oh that's all I
got so what the door did they get that
control come back I say not good PR for
Sony not at all you gotta come out they
have to address this to Charlene he's
kind of undressed this this is not good
for them because that is wrestling
anything say word
because he's on a throne of gold oh he's
looking down at you presence with his
wife he
that go falls on top of them that's all
they're not gonna be three has a real
they are announcing something that week
and I'm willing to bet they're
announcing something exactly when
Microsoft press comma I don't think OB
an obeah after when the news is coming
out I don't think they'll do it daring
that would be stupid to do it I don't I
don't know man but I mean they would do
it after when I gene and all them are
starting to write up the articles on
what's going on that's when they'll do
it because you know daring it there's a
chance that you won't you'll still get
some traction but even the Sony bad boys
now if you announce the the the release
day for last of us at that time
oh no it's a lot of thunder it would
take thunder but but people aren't gonna
stop watching watch him you know it'll
galvanize the base that they all have a
release date for one of the arguably one
of most anticipated titles they have in
the base yeah you get you you throw that
you throw a little JPEG and you throw
that you know whatever the date I mean
let's be honest when we saw that the
Star Wars I was like yo November this
yeah I didn't expect that you know base
so doubt that does have some a fake ID I
don't you saw what map is to tell us ed
about Star Wars that release days ago
this makes things interesting for q4 yes
there's your sales for games date they
putting a chest out right in Co DS wheel
outs to like they mascara product yeah
yes sir all right so let's go let's get
hop this leapfrog into the control
exclusivity uh no I know Cod wanted
every throws my last with you all right
so let's talk about it so uh there's
been some talk about basically the deal
that 505 games made with Playstation and
to have exclusive content for their
version of control tower
the game from remedy entertainment the
guys from that made Alan Wake the guys
that made Max Payne and the guys that
made quantum break so it's been a lot of
outcry in regards to what the
PlayStation fan base is receiving as
opposed to the PC fan base and the of
course the Xbox fan base so you guys
tell me what you feel about this is it
warranted is it not warranted are we
whining are we crying what was the like
right down what exactly is part of the
exclusive I still I think Brad you have
well you had a tweet yeah Brad out of
big cuz I know Brad was on this oh he's
on it yeah he told you he'll be right
back with nobody does anybody know what
the exclusivity aspects of I actually
have the hot information if nobody wants
it I'll basically it says I think seven
pieces of DLC is cosmetic but the the
the two major hiccups here are actual
missions actual gameplay missions that
the Xbox will never get to me look I
gotta be honest with you um you know I
know King and I we talked about Phil
Spencer a lot because we're big fans of
his right you know Phil Dominus Spencer
as I'm known on this podcast okay and
you know he a lot of people gave him
[ __ ] for not saying that you know he
doesn't want to keep Connie
we're in flavors right oh sorry about
that yes at the Lord's Day that is
correct so they you know why people gave
them you know stuff about not you know
about saying publicly we don't want to
hold content from from gamers right I'm
was like well you know you should go to
the should go for the jugular should be
like Sony and lock down these one-year
deals and and you know people come to
your system and you see a deal like this
listen I'm buying control I'm a fan of
remedy I'm of course getting it on the
Xbox one X which is gonna run in 4k my
bite on the epoch store never plays but
the whole problem
the ish the issue with this deal isn't
just cosmetics right it's not it's it's
it's to actual I don't know how lengthy
they are I can't say they're half an
hour I can't say they're 15 minutes it
could be 10 minutes roll we know but the
fact that this content for a game that's
on multiple platforms that is being
locked behind a deal and you want to you
know if you want to keep themes and you
want to keep avatar items and a special
gun on your console you know with a
weapon skin or something I don't have a
problem with that
my problem is that there are actually
two missions that I'm not gonna be able
to because I was buying it on the
PlayStation I'm sorry I let me joking it
is oldest of what I would hear they I'm
boom I'm with you to the letter of the
law right and all I must say is where
was this energy from gamers with the axe
is going on Xbox players were crying
they didn't have Jade rabbit they did
have missions they didn't have crucible
maps they didn't have anyone severe I
mean we were on the front line like this
is the most not only were they don't
we're still we've never got stuff they
promised yes felt it was anti-consumer
in everybody was on road you pay for the
exclusivity that's what you get you just
play on that place alright so me I don't
have the sympathy anymore right now
that's why I'm like it's funny that epic
store is in the mix too I love it
because at the end of the day listen is
it to the light is it a sheisty practice
absolutely you know I'm saying but
gamers got to keep that same energy and
let's be real my whole thing with this
whole thing with on what remedy is this
we got to be true the game before they
launch was quantum break and control we
have to admit it's kind of similar in
that realm right yeah it's simple I saw
it behind scenes III last year saw some
more of a that packs me king of solve so
more of it looks great but it's more
than that in a help we have to be real
to remedy took a big financial loss when
it came out as an Xbox exclusive what
and break we gotta call it for what it
was it was not a big success they was so
to me this is them trying to hedge their
bet with these exclusivity deals and now
go across and that's the thing if you
want to do go cross faction and they
don't don't behave like it like a second
party for Xbox right if you if you break
up with somebody right are you going
right back to them to for that for the
to know you you're going to play the
field so it's obvious that they were
going to go to Sony they were gonna go
to Sony and Sony was gonna open up the
checkbook and say what can we give you
together a bill of goods on quantum
break alright I thought they was sold a
bill of goods Microsoft purchased these
studios and that was when they were TV
TV TV and you know they had some hell of
odd actors I'm not gonna lie they really
did all the way up cause remember when
the first day yeah they had no names in
the and then exchanger oh yeah this do
face from game problems like broke and
they had Chuck back that's that's a
reference that kind of a lesbo Tech was
in the building
I'm down with all of this right and I'm
saying oh this is so legit if you
actually worked how they wanted it to
work
and Remini would've blew like boom
didn't anything fell to the floor I
respect I know what to be what they're
doing like they look at that they try to
hedge your bet they're trying to get the
most out of this hmm these as much as
possible with exclusivity and as far as
the epic stone you know epic probably
threw some cash their way or whatever
the only thing I gotta admit though I do
feel is a little sheisty
is that chart I don't know if y'all saw
that charters to charting cuz it's more
on the x5 side this tiny is a tiny
little chart and then the PlayStation
this is crazy like hey okay real quick
oh good a breath because like I it's not
anti-consumer I've seen people say this
is anti-consumer signing to consumer you
are getting the same the two to get the
two or the additional gameplay mission
on the ps4 it's gonna cost you more
money it's $80 right to get back this
$60 version is the same you were gonna
have the same gameplay experience on the
Xbox and as you were on the PlayStation
4
- a couple outfits maybe a gun or two
you know big deal whatever you know it's
so it's not like this outrage I just
don't understand it like it's kind of
ridiculous a little suspect right you
know what it is right
what's that it's everybody's for
sensitive rations on the other side
that's not supposed to happen because
you're special
do you see where this little mindset has
permeated every little aspect of our
stuff and this is not healthy but it's
how powerful this little this little
exclusivity thing is when we were at PAX
and shout outs a hip hop gamer and he
pulled us into his interview people
listen to the interview with the control
right you guys made love he like he but
when he got into the conversation about
hey you know I'm running the twenty atti
what's up with that rate race and I
heard that ray-tracing is fantastic and
and the dev looked at him he's like you
know we're at the PlayStation booth
right I'm not talking any ray-tracing to
you right now at all at all so it goes
to show the power of what these backroom
deals can do and it again it's it's it's
it's good business honestly
it's like imagine that all right an
exclusive detail where they won't even
talk about what they won't talk about
the platform that is odd and of their
but that's why that's why they make
these deals oh it's business and you
know in the end of the day they're like
like I said like if you're not gonna get
a different experience if you played on
the Xbox first the PlayStation 4 you're
not if you play if you pay the $60
retail version if you want to get the
extra game play or the extra mission you
gonna pay for it
I be 80 bucks I think the question dough
comes down okay right don't bother you
don't buy if you if you never guess but
the question is gonna be how long what's
the length of exclusivity in that
content because what I care about
control Wow Wow yeah yeah with the $10
super chat many people saw him for a
boys why I'm ready to jump for joy for
control which is a spiritual success at
a quantum break same engine saying game
place in graphics you're just playing as
a girl I got a kind of green what kid
like I saw a lot of control button again
I felt like it almost felt like this was
the sequel with just destroy we
immediately felt it feels like it's an
evolution of what they try to do with
that - all the TV stuff like I heard
it's like a supernatural type of thing
like if I've heard people say it's a
combination of like Alan Wake and they
go get that money back or listen listen
I gotta take this out check this out
listen remember that thing that we
kicking around earlier you take control
all right
okay listen work on that gun or what we
reload okay okay can we use the assets
here we have to use the same engine go
ahead and use the same engine if you see
the same face actors like if they get a
cut screen by mistake nobody honest the
protagonist in control I thought I don't
want to spoil anything for anybody who
didn't play for quantum break but the
but the girl that gets lost in time I
mean I could have sworn the protagonist
in in control with her
you know I was a huge fan of quantum
break I played like two hours of it and
I dropped that game but it didn't sell
well cause it was 900p see at some point
it was 700 720p control looks better but
like when I'm comparing stuff like
quantum break to control like it just I
can't describe to you guys how much I
don't like caught him break okay so I
don't really even remotely care anything
about control because I just don't get
you know I played it it didn't seem like
the game had good pacing had like
nothing like that like it just felt like
I was paying playing like a berated game
like it really did like what like a
b-movie
right and that's the best part about you
you have the people that say that remedy
hasn't been the same since Max Payne
yeah many people who don't let because
quite have a beta and I don't like their
best what about the people who say is
from the standpoint that if they're
paying $60 that they're not getting the
same exact content and don't but but
they are get the same gameplay
experience come you know that's that's
the point
upset over t-shirts said it was a
mission it's two missions actually it's
the one I'm looking at the chart I'm
mission its digital version you pay $80
for okay school it's not it's not it
it's that unlike an apples-to-apples
thing it's if you get the $60 version
you're gonna get cosmetics so that
doesn't impact gameplay or the actual
gameplay experience oh the thing about
it is well those in addition to the
dizzy
exclusive stuff you also have retail
exclusives and that's a that's a whole
nother level to do this right you have
specific exclusivity for certain things
at different retail stores whether it be
Game Stop will be Best Buy or whatever
they have that as well for buying the
physical copy so I'm done but that's not
but that doesn't impact like like if I
buy the play game on PlayStation 4 and
kognito buys it on Xbox one we play the
main story we're gonna have the same
experience regardless we have we are
because this stuff is cosmetic that
means people argued over the cosmetics
being like I don't think I'm with them
on this I'm done with the with these
deals like I'm not buy I wouldn't buy
control anyway so let's just be that
real I'm not boy goodbye but if I was
will buy control probably wouldn't buy
over this because after playing destiny
I no longer support these kind of deals
mm-hmm because because it doesn't matter
yeah I think Destiny's definitely more
agreed to seal because the point of
destiny is getting more guns and well
this is getting a straight face game
like this is a one-shot dunk where
however long this game is 59 pouring
these deals no matter what degree they
are they're gonna keep doing them right
but you got to pick your battles to I
don't know yeah because they're doing
stuff like this they won't do them
anymore
listen that's true addicts at a point
people buy them they will do it you got
Sony out here you got Michael sofa
everybody's trying to grab a piece of
this pie and it's full Amazon gun
jumping in then you gonna have to be
buying levels all over the complete
chicken or should it be okay for any
company to split their game into pieces
to give it to other platforms like it
just shouldn't be like it's the hey you
should not be sold their piece by piece
on me why because there we go no I hate
you I hate you but like you said we
trevor duality that's going on inside
and you you expect this but then you
turn around and say then don't buy and
that's that part right there that don't
buy guy that's the right guy the
expectation do expect nothing that don't
buy guy that's the guy that's gonna
dictate how the market is gonna go like
what's going on right over there if the
masses do not ride on the epic store and
they go over there and they buy the one
from um and mice or whoever then that
thing didn't sell and it wasn't a good
experiment it was a failed project and
it won't go to it and we visit that
again mmm I don't mind exclusives in
general I do mind selling pieces to
games to other people for highs bidder
you shouldn't cut stuff out of a game to
make more money off the game and then
sell the same product to another
consumer for the same price I mean that
the whole practice of DLC is that in a
sense right literally with the game
industry even getting away with just
deals community bought single player
games mmm we wouldn't have he LC if
people held these dudes to a standard
because when games used to come out
before there were games and now it
they're upset yeah up shop once that
online happened days or a new revenue
stream and yeah we can piecemeal
half-baked broken game to you and beeps
on the damn fly like she's been doing
for years so everybody's been talking
about or they don't want to be PC but
every day we get closer and closer to
being exactly that a PR PC that's inside
your liver hooked up to your television
and there's nothing different
pretty much like idea you have these
companies an inch they don't they're
gonna throw a couple football fields my
beginning they were doing this early
access thing to like one or two games
now every first party game they have has
an early access program like if and you
know why because stupid people like me
thirsty
it's the same thing like I guarantee you
if this kind of practice continues like
the middle of next generation you'll
start to see massive stuff like almost
every other game has a destiny agreement
yeah sure that's what's the heirs are
the future of gaming like I think about
singable
like player experiences and I think
about the what I call the 49th effect
yeah like what's gonna happen like Pete
cuz I look at my kids like their their
expectation of gaming is so much
different than mine yeah like you know
so I don't know and I think that's been
a ball that's what that's gonna be
that's gonna be one of the big things to
look at as you know these new consoles
get announced and all this online you
know whatever this cloud connectivity or
stuff gets gets kind of put out there
it's gonna be what how our expectations
as old-school gamers change because
listen how are ya oh we do would
definitely dinosaurs that's what our
expectation was a complete game that is
done yeah you don't get a complete game
no more we go into the store now knowing
the couch knowing that the game we're
purchasing right now is not going to be
the same game six to eight weeks from
now even being done on a DLC standpoint
the original destiny Kuroda was done and
they locked it on the desk like they it
was done they locked it on a ditch into
the first DLC yeah so these practices
will always continue to go forward but
what they're doing is they're beating
you into submission and lay down bro
that's all it I feel like like as like
consumers though because we could stop
that arcade machine go lock yourself you
don't have to talk to nobody you can
play your game complete by yourself you
want to engage with others and you want
to play how others are playing right now
this is the only ways get out of lay
down I think when I was like I said like
be picky you have to pick your battles
in that regard though because they're
gonna listen it obviously the destiny
thing was egregious that was crazy
this less so I don't know they like how
many people really gonna soapbox for
this for a mission stuff they're giving
is worthless but at the end of the day
it's like these kind of marketing deals
should not be a poet at all because
they're I mean if you need a if you need
something to the point of a a chart to
show when stuff comes up that's right
there's crazy like remember how much hey
Anthony
yeah well it's like no one's remembering
that hey absolutely people took that
chart and made fun of her for five to
ten minutes was that they messed up with
how they released a game people to
access it early on some platforms and
not it was it was messed up that was
that was just messed up you you you you
didn't control the narrative around long
to you and let that happen you know
outside of your control that was crazy
any attic Excel spreadsheets like what
we get that's pretty much it like sorry
well all that you know all that crying
all that attack you know my guy hit
Metacritic wise a little bit but the
game still sold well yeah like it's a
lot like it takes Star Wars Battlefront
that's one of the only things I've ever
seen the community joined forces like
that besides 2013 Xbox we have you for
you want to touch your your final
fantasy topic quickly or are you want to
do hey little TV first I gotta go you're
out okay
so we'll touch up on it a little bit but
we'll go with DS with days with Kings uh
topic first halo TV did this is
interesting be in here so so cod do we
have you for this uh stay for King to
say and then after day I'll comment in
our I have to hang cool right okay so
the halo TV series they're talking about
they're actually gonna do it alright so
we've been dying to get the movie with
and dying to get the TV shows
and all the stuff is coming now this guy
from 343 executive producer kiki wolf
kill I said that you know they're gonna
stick to the adaption of 343 properties
but according to wolf kill then going to
stick to Cannon at the expense of what
makes sense
hmm this what might change the patient's
needs and ethnicities Oh characters so
when we say stuff like that we might get
a Puerto Rican hello for diversity
Master Chief yes brother
ah now let's go my eyebrow we've done
that this is the time that they're
actually going to push the narrative
forward and bring some change to a
universe that has been stagnant and in
stuck in its ways and I just wanted to
bring that to you guys to see how it's
so tight the addict is gone because I
just know I live it right there well I
mean look yeah real quick oh you know
what I mean um
cog do you you want to give you a you
know I'm okay for change you know
obviously be seen it in Marvel Comics
with spider-man right we've seen him we
see Miles Morales and he's fantastic
character his backstory is magnificent
family multiracial really great story
did not change the Master Chief's race
creed color or anything didn't they're
not gonna do that because we know what
John you know 1 1 7 it is underneath
that underneath who he is right but we
don't actually really know so you can
they could they could you know change it
and you know what he's gonna still be
the master Cheever because of what race
he is right I mean I I mean if people
really kind of put their stake in the
ground I have to question their their
humanity because it's it's it's a game
number one number two does it really
matter who saved the
world of you know 600 times right does
it doesn't matter um but I I think that
the statement from Kiki wolf kill which
by the way is an awesome name and I see
she actually talked a lot on on the last
at you know inside x-ray she was on that
she was talking about the halo
experience which is dope I think if
they're gonna make some changes I don't
think they're gonna be so egregious that
people gonna be running for the hills
and burn halo flags I think they have to
make this show livable and
understandable you know the people that
are first gonna just cuz you gotta
remember not everyone knows about halo
so you're gonna get a lot of casuals
they're gonna be like what is this new
space series and they met that might be
their first iteration of the Halo
universe and I think you know besides
catering to the fanbase they also have
to cater to new people joining the fray
mmm
interesting I mean look all this stuff
as far as like you know inclusion you
know that's long overdue right with the
verse I agree we definitely want to see
that I think where it always comes down
to is when there's a fan base that have
beloved characters and then that
ethnicity or sexuality or you know
whatever gender has changed then you
know certain people who have an
attachment to the character let's just
call it for what it is we all know this
subject is about chief in a sense
because you go people certain groups may
feel away if that is changed I just find
this kind of stuff is it's it's
hilarious to me none of this stuff
really affects me per se but um I it's
always interesting to me when I see
games do that because on you know not to
get too political some people like oh
this sgw thing I mean even your video
saw when you did the Kingdom Come
deliverance right exactly
I look at the comments and shout first
was out this all shout the King got
killed that 20,000 views wow it's
amazing but um it's funny out watching
about the woman's lot DLC right and
people are sitting there like fight this
is not you know they're going in the
sexist sexist they all go it is just
really interesting to see that these
type
things really affect certain groups of
people me out of here either way it's
true king he said dominican master chief
would like it was a lot of talk about
denzel one of the greatest actors of our
time do you listen that's like giving
Samuel Jackson sorry bro like I don't
need I don't need that I mean you gotta
remember to like there was remember the
big outcry over the witcher series
battlefield when they had sexism know
that part right there the whole sexism
stuff we got a community as sexes I
don't like that and I thought it was
actually hi and then when they had to be
corrected and have to be told that women
was on the battlefield and women were
carrying out this stuff listen maybe
y'all needed to go watch king of statues
and get some respect for women and
understand that Lynda Carter is at the
forefront wonder women whips but
understand that is true that these women
are strong so cut that out guys yeah
you're gonna take your fake minutes
we look forward to seeing you next week
correct anything happens but Lord
kognito is just when just when you go
out to go down he jumps in okay you
gonna see a change in good hands
so with that man list let's head into
our final topic really quickly this is
addicts topic really you don't want a
passion for this topic at all in any
form or fashion I just roll him to death
and if he's not here for the trolling
I'm not gonna waste it bullying what do
you guys feel you guys are gonna stop it
tweet me I'm okay we pass on it you know
it's beautiful and that's - we'll call
it a show once again thank you ignored
brat Thank You Lourdes boom thank you
for returning to the realm and joining
us you guys a family you guys are
absolutely amazing so please let us know
what you guys are doing where you guys
gonna be boom boom I know where you're
gonna be man a couple of weeks we're
gonna be hanging out chilling it's
fantastic so let us know what you guys
are up to man army can you go first my
brother yeah you go ahead man you go
ahead all right well I'm obviously you
know I have three live shows coming up
this week like I'm
a few people said it on the podcast
already I am one of the busiest guys
going I you know what I bully myself to
be better
I really do I know that sounds silly but
I really do because you know you know
when people listen to the shows you have
to understand people are taking the time
out of their day to listen to you right
and that's because they become fans I
honestly pinched myself that I get
anybody to listen to my shows to be
quite honest with you I really do so I
go out of my way to make sure that each
and every episode of whatever show I'm
doing is better than the next one and
that's where that's where the bullying
comes from I don't stand on law laurels
I want to keep pushing myself and make
myself better if you're interested in
lots of live content I really just throw
it out there suggest if you you've never
heard of me check out double-barrel
gaming on YouTube I'm closing in on
twenty four hundred subs I'm closing in
on three thousand followers on Twitter
which is a big deal and listen you're
always going to get honesty you get
you're gonna get positivity and honesty
and I juice and Lanikai Thank You van
lots of passion I support all three
consoles I have all the best editions
over the mall because I love gaming I'm
a gamer at the end of the day I'm not an
Xbox game or a PlayStation game or a
Nintendo game or I'm a gamer so if you
want to listen to opinions from a gamer
check out my channel and you know what
hit me up in the DM the dm's open to
everyone on twitter i'm actually was
just answering somebody in twitter right
now that was saying that he just found
the channel so thank you for that and
you know what like I said check out
Wednesday gaming news at noon with salty
and boom the Xbox tractor podcast we
have a special guest from you know you
know from avoid bastards that's gonna be
on the air on you know on our show it's
gonna be a big deal and breakfast with
boom you know it's got another big show
come hang out I guarantee you're gonna
enjoy something maybe all three and once
again this hanging out with you guys is
always an honor because you guys are
family everyone on this panel you know
you guys are family and to be going to
e3 with you literally is it like a dream
come true and I cannot wait to get there
yeah we can't we can't agree more man
like honestly you are one of the the
nicest people I have ever had the
pleasure that
first with a true gentleman a can say
the same for Braswell you guys are
absolutely embody what this community
should aspire to at all times
thanks to anybody out there in the chat
that hasn't followed these guys had
doesn't know about their content go to
their channels all of that stuff was
gonna be in the show notes at the end go
see what these guys are about they're
amazing content creators they really are
so thank you so much Lord boom or Bratz
man let us know what's going on man I
just want to say thank you guys for
having me oh yeah it really is a
pleasure and an honor to be on with you
guys you guys are like family seriously
boom you're like family to man I mean
you know uh the the one thing I always
bring this up when I do a podcast boom
boom and I don't always agree with
things especially becomes a gaming media
but it's okay but I like to bring that
because I always feel like you know
there's this there's this level of
identity politics that's kind of creeped
into gaming I feel like a common bond
that we have is that we're all gamers
whether or not we agree or disagree the
fact of the matter is we all have this
passion for for gaming and and and that
should never be forgotten and so on that
note I just want to say gentlemen thank
you again for having me on it's been a
pleasure you guys are like family
anyways listening if you haven't checked
out basement where the arcade podcast
you can find us on youtube if you do a
quick search on YouTube debates for any
arcade podcast you can follow me on
twitter at rap be our AP underscore
podcast and please if you haven't sub to
the iron Lords or double-barrel gaming
do so great content gentlemen thank you
again thank you man thank you coming
through man I really appreciate you guys
and man braaap you got a yeah we got to
figure this out man you got to come to
pax with us and you got to come to to
e31 and I want
it's gonna happen one day just it's hard
man when I've you know we understand
whole spiel listen yeah breath I told
you I can actually map it out for you
it's very easy there's a boom listen
boom I did way live this is it doesn't
cost as much it's not as much as it is
understand logistically other things
happen Amelie yes that's a different
thing like when you gotta coordinate
children because it's a partnership so I
get that part but as far as financially
I come at it all out I'm the marketing
genius yes he is boy hey hey King and I
hope I hope at this year's e3 you can
join us on Brad because you did last
year
oh I'm gonna be on deal I'm gonna be on
everybody who actually wants me on a
show so in the compound the compound
scene it's compounded Lord King gave us
the tour step up and next year compound
what we're gonna do I got news even Rica
this compound is such the real deal that
I was on the corner and I was collecting
cans to make sure that my payment went
in through the head of the iron bank to
make sure that there was no hiccups in
this I was getting the room that I was
promised right now I showed it to my
brother and he was like you know you
this is this is this is dreams what
you're showing me great mental man
what's up he's got he's got to come with
us too you know what I got a guy got to
get in you know he we're gonna try and
work something well he comes with us
next year cuz we were talking about it
you know he just bought a house he just
bought a home so you know you know money
was a little tight so but yeah next next
year we make we may get Neil mental and
double-barrel gaming to be at the same
fantastic so again thank you guys for
coming through we love you guys much
appreciated Lord came tell everybody
what you up to bro let's say this I know
this is their Kos coming our way
I am I'm giving you that real I mean you
know that real-deal Holyfield feel baby
but fights coming up so we got a king
statues that's on Wednesday Wednesday
7:00 a.m. and then we also have and and
that drops listen like follow subscribe
on all platforms yep on on the Facebook
community on the Twitter on the
Instagram because you're gonna get
different content at different places
and hope you too and go to Lourdes a
gaming dotnet it's it's one ecosystem
that we're trying to keep you in so you
can get everything alright so like if
like this it's like it's just like
gaming if your game over here we got
something for you over there it's not
just Xbox this is playstation would you
guess which guy right here the guys in
charge of the ship right now which do be
careful the other guy that's away or
sick leave he's a switch do but he's
always playing on playstation watch out
I'm the only one that's you've gone in
this front real green dude I'm I keep it
100% filled ominous away you see we is
on like let's check it out the going to
e3 this year we got some stuff that's
gonna be epic I'm getting as far as the
marketing direction and unified front
every podcast that's out there that we
mess with we're gonna interact with you
alright and we're going to do it in such
a fashion that we're gonna make last
year's e3 pale in comparison if you
thought we were out here moving in last
year's e3 and you can go to the YouTube
channel and you can see all the stuff
that we were doing we will move the
needle this year I told you last year we
was going to trend hot monkeys loving
was trending with Phil diamond and
Spencer alright so understand that we
will trend again this year how and why
you gotta tune in alright so make sure
you all like follow subscribe iron loves
podcast make sure to go to the YouTube
page the Instagram the Facebook Lords of
gaming dotnet make sure you get linked
consider because you have opinion pieces
from boom from brat from these family
members that here which has eight
fantastic pieces of writing beautiful so
enjoy doing it - yeah love it I love
these guys and we keep it real we're not
we're not joking around on war plan but
we also have um combat talk with the
King and that's going up every week
because we have some really heavy
hitting fights that's going through and
I changed the format a little bit I'm
gonna change it again soon I'm gonna get
a green screen guys I take all your
information and I and I see how it works
for me and then I try to give you the
best content with the best visuals and
the best insights that I can bring to
you shout out the Fonzarelli for always
supporting me I love you brother things
I found out no doubt so yeah I mean King
king is always machinate man we know
that every year he's gonna be a special
thing his king is his mind's always
running what can we do different what
can we do better so I already know that
there's some craziness in tow for us and
I can't wait for it
alright so of course is Lord sovereign
here you can find me at north/south ILP
on Twitter and bxr and on PSN and xbox
live big shout out to everybody that
that's in the chat today that was
listening today thank you so much for
the support guys you guys are amazing
like I said last last week you guys are
in the chat like hours ahead of time
Laura Lugo is always there like a couple
of hours of make sure he's always the
first one so we appreciate that love and
dedication to our podcast we really
appreciate everything and we love you
guys
big shout out to everybody on the stream
team Lords now doe l-boogie
Dino well MJ the boss and of course he's
gonna be a III MJ's everywhere man MJ
that the name is getting out there man
and he's really finding his his footing
in terms of streaming and just being out
there with us so yeah mmm J is really
really coming up so I really I really
like what he's doing and of course
everybody at Lords of gaming dotnet you
guys you know where to go for all your
gaming news reviews opinions there are
some amazing pieces up there we just
talked about what
lord boomded and what what lord brab did
we have pieces up about Socorro we have
pieces of about destiny so go to log
Lords of gaming dotnet check it out
shout out to dizzy and everybody over
there and on the editing team on the
writing team we actually have a few
surprises still to announce I'll leave
that to the boss to announce but we have
some things to talk about but I'll leave
that to cog to bring up so big shout out
to that I'm out I'm Christopher Hart III
has been cancelled for you
I appreciate me to the very last second
he's guy he's holding the flag
Christopher Hart is amazing bad so
amazing that he doesn't care it could be
two seconds before the end of the show
he's gonna make sure that the Sony
counters the colors fly so I appreciate
that yeah and look out for the audio
Lord Kaiba who should be handling that
later on today shoutout to Lord kayo was
taking care of everybody so if you want
it listen to our podcast on iTunes
SoundCloud Google Play Store and Spotify
all that stuff is gonna be going up
later alright so thank you again guys
enjoy the rest of your Sunday
enjoy Game of Thrones Sunday anybody
who's throwing Game of Thrones watching
parties enjoy so everybody first episode
always sucks for the throne no they
can't suck suck gonna die we don't want
to die guaranteed so once again thank
you guys enjoy the rest of your Sunday
and we're out peace